for more parents are pleading guilty in
the College Admission scandal
prosecutors are threatening to add
bribery charges and additional prison
time for parents who have yet to cut a
deal this could happen as soon as today
in all 19 parents have pleaded guilty
the sentences so far have ranged from
probation to five months behind bars Don
Dahler reports on the parents who are
now changing their pleas Douglas Hobbs
the ex CEO of investment firm PEMCO
leaving federal court in Boston after
pleading guilty to mail fraud and money
laundering charges Hodge was accused of
paying five hundred twenty-five thousand
dollars to get his two children into the
University of Southern California and
Georgetown University he is one of the
latest in a growing number of high
profile parents changing their pleas
from not guilty to guilty CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clayman some of the
parents learned that there might be a
new charge that would be filed by the
prosecution having to do with federal
bribery so they decided they'd better
plead guilty and they'd better do it now
the other parents changing their pleas
to guilty on Monday were among the most
lucrative clients of Ric singer the
alleged mastermind of the scam including
hot pocket heiress Michelle genese and
Elizabeth Henriques and her husband
Manuel
a former finance CEO who is dyslexic and
read a statement of apology and it was
very difficult for him to read and to be
able to speak the words without crying
they will all be sentenced next year
still holding out for trial actress Lori
Lachlan and her a fashion designer
husband accused of paying $500,000 to
get their two daughters into USC Lori
Loughlin and her husband have not yet
cut a deal we can only wonder why
because the longer they continue to hold
out the worse it will be for them for
CBS this morning
I'm Don Dahler sure would like to be a
fly on the wall with the conversation
they must be having as they're watching
all of this happen around them maybe
changing their minds and saying your
honor I'm so sorry
maybe they're getting different legal
advice and Ricky Clemens given they
should call Ricky